the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we've been talking about this
chi-square test and the name K Square
comes from the fact that we build a test
statistic that has asymptotic
distribution given by the chi-squared
distribution let's just give it another
shot ok and this tests who has actually
ever encountered the chi-square test
outside of a stats fast room all right
so some people have write it's a fairly
common test that you might encounter and
it was essentially to test if given some
data with a fixed probability mass
function right so discrete distribution
you wanted to test if it was given the
PMF was equal to a set value P naught or
if it was different from P naught and
the way the chi-square arose here was by
looking at waltz test and essentially if
you write a wealth is the one that has
the chi-square as the limiting
distribution and if you invert the
covariance matrix the asymptotic
covariance matrix so you compute the
Fisher information which in this
particular case does not exist for the
Milton multinomial distribution but we
found the trick on how to do this we
remove the part that forbid it to be
invertible then we found this chi-square
distribution so in a way we have this
test statistic which you might have
learned as a black box laundry list but
going through the math which might have
been slightly unpleasant I acknowledge
but really told you why you should do
this particular normalization so since
some of you requested a little more you
know practical examples of how those
things work let me show you a couple the
first one is the you want to answer the
question well you know when should I be
born
to be successful right and you know some
people believe in zodiac and so Fortune
magazine actually collected the signs of
256 houses of the fortune 500 right
those were taken randomly and they were
collected there and you can see this
this the count of number of CEOs that
have a particular zodiac sign and if
this was completely uniformly
distributed you should actually get a
number that's around 256 divided by 12
which in this case is 21 point 33 okay
you can see that there is numbers that
you know are probably in the vicinity
but see look at this guy this is right
that's 29 so whose piece is here all
right and all right so give me your
information and we'll meet again in 10
years and so basically you might want to
test if actually the fact that it's
uniformly distributed is a valid
assumption now this is clearly a random
variable I pick a random CEO and I
measure what is zodiac sign is and I
want to know if this so it's a probably
over I don't know 12 zodiac signs and I
want to know if it's uniform or not
right uniform sounds like it should be
the status quo if you're reasonable and
and maybe there's actually something
that moves away so you know we could do
this in view of this data is there
evidence that one is different
here's another example where you might
want to apply the chi-square test all
right so as I said the benchmark
distribution was the uniform
distribution for the zodiac Sun and
that's usually the one I gave you 1 over
K 1 over K because well that's sort of
the zero you know the central point for
all distributions right that's the point
that's right at the center of what we
call the simplex but you can have
another benchmark that sort of makes
sense right so for example this is an
actual data set were two hundred and
fifty and seventy-five jurors were
identified with identified racial group
were collected and you actually might
want to know if you know juries in this
country are actually representative of
the actual population and so here of
course the population is not uniformly
distributed according to racial group
and the way you actually do it is you
actually go on Wikipedia for example and
you look at the demographic
the United States and you find that the
proportion of white is 72% like 7%
Hispanic is 12 and other is well about
9% so that's a total of 1 and this is
what we actually measured for some
jurors so for this guy you can actually
run the chi-square test right you have
the estimated proportion which comes
from this first line you have the tested
proportion p0 that comes with the second
line and you might want to check if
those things actually correspond to each
other okay so I'm not gonna do it for
you but I sort of invite you to do it
and test and see how this compares to
the quantiles of the appropriate
chi-square distribution and see what you
can conclude from those to fix all right
so this was the multinomial okay so this
is essentially what we did we computed
the MLE and they're the right constraint
and that was our test statistic that
converges to the chi-square distribution
so if you've seen it before that's all
that was given to you now we know why
the normalization here is P naught J and
not P not J squared or square root of P
now J or even 1 right I mean it's not
clear that this should be the right
normalization but we know that's what
comes from taking the right
normalization which comes from the
Fisher information all right
ok so the thing I wanted to move on to
so we've basically covered K squared
test are there any questions about K
quiz there's K squared test and for
those of you who were not here on
Thursday I'm really just I do not
pretend I just did it right that's
something we did last Thursday
all right the are there any question
that arose when you were reading your
notes things that you didn't understand
yes
so so it's it's not so it's not the
Fisher and the Fisher information does
not exist in this case and so there's no
appropriate name for this is the
pseudo-inverse of the synthetic revenge
matrix and that's what it is and there's
I don't know if I mentioned it last time
but there's this entire field that uses
you know for people who are really
aspire to differential geometry but are
stuck in it's that's Department and
there's this thing called information
geometry which is essentially studying
the manifolds associated to the Fisher
information matrix and the the metric
that's associated to Fisher information
right and so those of course can be
lower dimensional manifolds not only
distorts the geometry but forces
everything to live on the lower
dimension which is what happens when you
Fisher information does not exist and so
you know there's a bunch of things that
you can study what this manifold looks
like etc but no there's no particular
terminology here about about going here
to be fair within the scope of this
class this is the only case where you
Milton you multinomial case is the only
case where you typically see a lack of
Fisher information matrix and that's
just because we have this extra
constraints that the some of the
parameter should be one and if you have
an extra constraint that seems like it's
actually removed one degree of freedom
this will happen inevitably and so maybe
what you can do is repair match Reaper
amateur eyes so if I actually repair
American formed in function of P 1 to P
K minus one and then one minus the sum
this would not have happen because I
have only a k-dimensional space so
there's tricks around this to make it
exist if you want it to exist any other
question all right so let's move on to
students T tests we mentioned that last
time right so essentially you've
probably done it more even in homework
than you've done it in in lectures but
just quickly this is essentially the
test that's the test when we have an
actual data that comes from a normal
distribution there's no central limit
theorem that exists this is really to
account for the fact that for smaller
sample sizes it might be the case
it's not exactly true that when I look
at xn bar minus mu / so if I look at xn
bar minus mu divided by Sigma times
square root of n then this thing should
have n 0 1 distribution approximately
right by the central limit theorem so
that's for n large but if any small then
it's still true when the data is n nu
Sigma squared then it's true that square
root of n so here it's approximately and
this is always true but I don't know
Sigma in practice right maybe nu it
comes from my maybe nu comes from my new
knot right maybe something from the the
test statistic where mu actually is here
but for this guy I'm gonna have
inevitably to find an estimator and now
in this case for small n this is no
longer true and what the T statistic is
doing is essentially telling you what
the distribution of this guy is all
right so the true what you should say is
that now this guy has a T distribution
with n minus 1 degrees of freedom
that's basically the you know laundry
list stats that you would learn it says
just look at a different table that's
what it is but we actually defined was 8
what a T distribution was and a T
distribution is basically something that
has the same distribution as some n 0 1
divided by the square root of a
chi-squared with d degrees of freedom
divided by d and that's a T distribution
with degrees of freedom right and those
two have to be independent okay and so
what I need to check is that this guy
over there is of this form
okay so let's look at the numerator well
square root of n xn bar minus mu what is
the distribution of this thing is it an
N 0 1 & 0 Sigma squared right
so I'm not going to put it here so if I
want this guy to be + 0 1 I need to
divide by Sigma that's what we have over
there so that's my n 0 1 that's gonna
play the role of this guy here so if I
want to go a little further I need to
just say okay now I need to have square
root of N and I need to find something
here that looks like my case square root
of Chi square divided by ya
no that's just the in distribution so I
don't know that's let's just write it
like that if you want I mean yeah that's
not really appropriate do you have
usually you write only one distribution
on the right hand side of this little
thing so not just this complicated
function of distributions I mean this is
more like to explain okay and so usually
you think you should say is that T is
equal to this X divided by square root
of Z divided by D where X has normal
distribution Z has chi-squared
distribution with the degrees of freedom
sir okay so what do I need here well I
need to have something which looks like
my Sigma hat right so somehow inevitably
I'm going to need to have Sigma hat now
of course I need to divide this by my
Sigma so that my Sigma goes away and so
now this thing here sorry I should move
on to the right okay and so this thing
here so Sigma hat is is square root of
SN and now I'm almost there so this
thing is actually equal to square root
of N
right
but this thing here is actually not a so
this thing here follows a distribution
which is actually a chi-square square
root of a chi-squared distribution
divided by and yeah that's the square
root K square distribution with n minus
1 degrees of freedom
divided by n because Sigma hat is equal
to 1 over n sum from I equal 1 to N X I
minus X bar squared and we just said
that this part here was a chi-squared
distributed we didn't just say it we
said it a few lectures back that this
thing with the chi-square distribution
and the fact that the presence of this
xn bar X X bar here was actually
removing one degree of freedom from this
sum ok so this guy here has the same
distribution as the Chi square n minus 1
divided by n so now I need to actually
still arrange this thing a little bit to
have a T distribution
I should not see n here but I should see
n minus 1 right the D here is the same
as this D here and so let me make the
correction so that this actually happens
well if I actually write this to be
equal to so if I write square root of n
minus 1 as on the slide times xn bar
minus mu divided by well let me write it
as square root of SN which is my Sigma
hat then what this thing is actually
equal to well it's it's it follows a n 0
1 divided by the square root of my
chi-square distribution with n minus 1
degrees of freedom and here the fact
that I multiplied by square root of n
minus 1 and I have the square root of n
here is essentially the same as dividing
here by n minus 1 right and that's my TN
distribution
my t-distribution with n minus 1 degrees
of freedom just by definition of what
this thing is okay
all right yes
this guy I'm sorry that's Sigma square
thank you that's just that's the
estimator of the variance not the
estimator of the standard deviation when
I want to divide I divide by standard
deviation thank you any other question
or remark the estimator for the variance
oh yes you're right so there's a Sigma
square here that what you're asking yes
yeah absolutely and that's where it get
cancels here it gets cancelled here okay
so this is really a Sigma squared times
K square
okay so the fact that it's Sigma square
is just because I can pull out Sigma
squared and just make those guys in zero
one right alright so that's my T
distribution now that I actually have a
pivotal distribution what I do is that I
form the statistic here I called it TN
tilde okay and what is this thing I know
that this has a pivotal distribution so
for example I know that the probability
that T and tilde in absolute value
exceeds some number that I'm gonna call
Q alpha over 2 for the TN minus 1 is
equal to alpha right so that's basically
remember the T distribution has the same
shape as the Gaussian distribution what
I'm finding is for this T distribution
some number Q alpha over 2 of TN minus 1
and minus Q alpha over 2 of TN minus 1
so those are different from the Gaussian
one such that the area under the curve
here is alpha over 2 on each side so
that the probability that my absolute
value exceeds this number is equal to
alpha and that's what I'm going to use
to reject the test right so now my test
become for a zero say mu is equal to
some new zero versus H 1 mu is not equal
to MU 0 is well the rejection region is
going to be equal to the set on which
square root of n minus 1 times xn bar
minus mu 0 this time divided by square
root of SN exceeds in absolute value
exceeds Q oh sorry there's already here
exceeds Q alpha over 2 of TN minus 1
okay so I reject when this thing
increases the same as the Gowen case
except that rather than reading my
quintiles from the Gaussian table I
breed them from the student table it's
just the same thing so they're just
gonna be a little bit farther right so
this guy here is just gonna be a little
bigger than the one for the Gaussian one
because it's gonna require me a little
more evidence in my data to be able to
reject because I have to account for the
fluctuations of Sigma hat okay so of
course students test is used everywhere
people use only Chi tests right that's
basically if you look at any data point
any output even if you had 500
observations if you look at the
statistical software output is gonna say
t-test and the reason why you see t-test
is because so that somehow it's felt
like it's not asymptotic you don't need
to actually do you know to be
particularly careful and anyway if n is
equal to five hundreds is the two curves
are above each other it's basically the
same thing so it doesn't really change
anything so why not using the t-test so
it's not asymptotic it doesn't require
central material to kick in and so in
particular it can be run if you have 15
observations of course the drawback of
the student tested that it relies on the
assumption that the sample is Gaussian
and that's something we really need to
keep in mind if you have a small sample
size there's no magic going on it's not
like student t-test allows you to get
rid of this asymptotic normality it sort
of assumes that it's built-in it assumes
that your data has a Gaussian
distribution so if you have 15
observations what are you gonna do you
want to test if the mean is equal to
zero or not equal to zero but you have
only 15 observations you have to somehow
assume that your data is Gaussian but if
the data is given to you this is not
math you actually have to check that
it's Gaussian and so we're gonna have to
find tests that given some data tells us
whether it's Gaussian or not if I have
15 observations eight of them are equal
to plus one and seven of them are equal
to minus one
and it's pretty unlikely that you're
gonna be able to conclude that your data
has a Gaussian distribution however if
you see some sort of spread around some
value you form a histogram maybe and it
sort of looks like it's a Gaussian one
you might want to say it's Gaussian
right and so how do we make this more
quantitative well the sad answer to this
question is that there will be some
tasks that make it quantitative but here
if you think about it for one second
what is going to be your null hypothesis
you're not I posses us since it's one
point it's going to be that it's gal
seein and then it's the alternative is
gonna be that it's not Gaussian so what
it means is that for the first time in
your statistics life you're gonna want
to conclude that's the h0 is the true
one you're definitely not gonna want to
see that it's not Gaussian because then
everything you know is sort of falling
apart and so it's kind of a weird thing
where you're sort of gonna be seeking
tests that have no power basically
you're gonna want test that and that's
what that's the nature the amount of
alternatives the number of ways you can
be not Gaussian is so huge that all
tests are sort of bound to have very low
power and so that's why people are
pretty happy with the idea that things
is Gaussian because it's very hard to
find a test that's gonna reject this
hypothesis
all right and so we're even gonna find
some tests that are visual where you're
gonna be able to say well sort of looks
Gaussian to me if it's all allows it
allows you to to deal with the
borderline cases pretty efficiently
we'll see actually a particular example
all right so this theory of testing
whether data comes from a particular
distribution is called goodness-of-fit
is this distribution a good fit for my
data that's the goodness of fit test we
have just seen a goodness of fit test
what was it
yeah the the the chi-square test right
the chi-square test we were given a
candidate PMF and we were testing if
this was a good fit for our data that
was a goodness-of-fit test
so of course multinomial is one example
but really what we have in the back of
our mind is I want to test if my data's
calcium that's basically the usual thing
and just like you always see t-test as
the standard output from statistical
software whether you ask for it or not
there will be a test for normality
whether you ask it or not from any
statistical software output all right so
again this a fantastic place fellows
you've given it there's a random
variable X and you're given iid copies
of X right X 1 to xn they come from the
same distribution and you're gonna ask
the following question that as X have a
standard normal distribution right so
for T distribution that's definitely the
kind of questions you may want to ask
does X have a uniform distribution on 0
1 right that's different from the
distribution 1 over K one of our kids
the continuous new notion of uniform
uniformity all right and for example you
might want to test that so there's
actually a nice exercise which is if you
look at the p-values right so we've
defined what the p values were and the p
value is a number between 0 & 1 right
and you could actually ask yourself what
is the distribution of the p-value under
the null right so it's a the p value is
a random random number it's the
probability right so the p value let's
look at a the following test a 0 mu is
equal to 0 versus H 1 mu is say not
equal to 0 and I know that the p value
is so I'm going to form what I'm gonna
look at xn bar minus mu divided by x
square root of n divided by let's say
that we know Sigma for one second all
right then the p value is the
probability that this is say larger than
square root of n little xn bar minus mu
minus 0 actually in this case right
/ Sigma where this guy is the observed
right okay so now you could say well how
is that a random variable right there's
just a number it's just a probability of
something but then I can view this as a
function of this guy here when I plug
plug it back it when I plug it back to
be a random variable so what I mean by
this is that if I look at this value
here this if i loo if I say that Phi is
the CDF of n 0 1 right so the p value is
the probability that it exceeds this so
that's the probability that I'm on
either here or here
okay no it's not right this is a big X
and this is a small X this is just where
you plug in your data do I have right
the p value of the brotherly you have
more evidence against your L to your
null than what you already have okay so
now I can write in an interpretive
cumulative distribution function right
so this is what this is Phi of this guy
which is minus this thing here well it's
basically two times this guy Phi of
minus square root of n xn bar divided by
Sigma right that's the value of my TV
that's my p value if you give me data
I'm gonna compute the average and plug
it in there and it's gonna spit out the
p value everybody agrees so now I can
view this if I start now looking back I
say well where does this data come from
well it could be a random variable right
it it came from the realization of this
thing so I can try to I can think of
this value or now this is a random
variable because I just plugged in a
random variable in here all right so now
I view my p value as a random variable
right so i keep on switching from small
x to large ax everybody agrees what i'm
doing here
so I just wrote it as a deterministic
function of some deterministic number
and now the number it the function stays
deterministic but the number becomes
random and so now I can think of this as
some statistic of my data and I could
say well what is the distribution of
this random variable now if my data is
actually normally distributed so I'm
actually under the null so under the
null that means that xn bar times
cordovan divided by Sigma has what
distribution normal
yeah well it was Sigma ice I assumed I
knew it right so it's n 0 1 right I
divided by Sigma here ok so now I have
this random variable and so my random
variable is now 2 Phi of minus absolute
value of a Gaussian okay and I'm
actually interested in the distribution
of this thing okay I could ask that
anybody has an idea of how you would
want to tackle this thing if I asked you
what is the distribution of a random
variable how do you tackle this question
there's basically two ways one is to try
to find something that looks like the
expectation of H of X for all H and you
try to write this using change of
variables as something that looks like
integral of H of X P of X DX and then
you say well that's the density right if
you can write this for any H then that's
the way you would do it but there's a
much simpler way that does not involve
changing variables etc you just try to
compute the cumulative distribution
function all right so let's try to
compute the probability that 2 Phi minus
n 0 1 is less than T and maybe we can
find something we know ok well that's
equal to what that's the probability
that a minus n 0 well let's say that an
N 0 1 I'm sorry
n 0 1 absolute value is greater than
minus Phi inverse of T over 2
right and that's basic that's what well
it's just the same thing that we had
before it's equal to so if I look again
this is the probability that I'm
actually on this side or that side of
this number and this number is what it's
minus Phi of T over two why do I have a
minus here that's fine okay so it's
actually not this it's actually the
probability at my absolute value because
Phi inverse okay because Phi inverse is
so I'm going to look at T between 0 and
so this number is ranging between 0 and
1 so it means that this number is
ranging between 0 well the probability
that something is less than T should be
ranging between the numbers that this
guy takes to so that's between 0 and 2
right right because this thing takes
values between 0 and 2 I want to see 0
and 1 now
yeah you're right thank you so this is
always some number which is less than
zero so the probability that the
Gaussian is less than this number is
always less than probabilities less than
zero which is one-half so T only has to
be between zero and one thank you and so
now for T that's between zero and one
then this guy is actually becoming
something which is positive for the same
reason as before and so that's what
that's just basically two times Phi of
Phi inverse of T over two okay that's
just playing with the symmetry a little
bit you can look at the areas under the
curve and so what it means is that those
two guys cancel this is the identity and
so this is equal to T so which
distribution has a this has a density as
a sorry which distribution has a
cumulative distribution function which
is equal to T for T between 0 & 1 that's
the uniform distribution right so it
means that this guy follows a uniform
distribution on the interval 0 1 okay
and you can actually check that for any
test you're gonna come up with this is
gonna be the case your p-value under the
null will have a distribution which is
uniform so now if somebody shows up and
says here's my test it's awesome it just
works great I don't know I'm not gonna
explain to you how I built it it's a
complicated statistics that involves
moments of order 27 and I'm like okay
you know how am I gonna test that your
test statistic actually makes sense well
one thing I can do is to run a bunch of
data draw a bunch of samples compute
your test statistic compute the p-value
and check if my p-value has a uniform
distribution on the interval 0 1 but for
that I need to have a test that's
allowed given a bunch of observations
can tell me whether they're actually
distributed uniformly on the interval 0
1 and again one thing I could do is
build a histogram
and see if it looks like that of a
uniform but I could also try to be
slightly more quantitative about this
for two tests no it's it's uniform under
than all right so because my my test
statistic was built under the no and so
I have to be able to plug in the right
value in there otherwise gonna shift
everything for this particular test
that's the p-value right that's the
finishing of the p-value
all right is the probability that my
test statistic exceeds what I've
actually observed yeah so my my p-value
is just this number when I just plug in
the values that I observe here right
that's one number for every data set
you're gonna give me there's gonna be
one number now what I can do is for
generate a bunch of data sets of size n
like 200 of them and then I'm gonna have
a new sample of size 200 which is just
the sample of 200 p-values and I want to
test if those p-values have a uniform
distribution okay because that's the
distribution they should be having all
right
okay this one we've already seen does X
have a PMF with you know 30% 50% and 20%
right that's something I could try to
test that looks like your grade point
distribution for this class all right
I'm not exactly but that looks like it
all right so so all these things are
know are known as goodness-of-fit tests
the goodness of fit test is something
that want to know if the data that you
have at hand has a follows a
hypothesized distribution all right so
it's not a parametric test it's not a
test that says is my mean equal to 25 or
not is my proportion of heads larger
than one-half or not it's something that
says is my distribution this particular
thing all right so I'm gonna read them
as goodness-of-fit gof here so here
there's you don't need to have
parametric modeling to do that so how do
I work right so if I don't have any
parametric modeling I need to have
something which is somewhat
nonparametric right something that goes
beyond computing the mean and the
standard deviation something that
computes some intrinsic nonparametric
aspect of my data and just like here we
made this computation what we did is we
said well if I actually check that the
CDF of my data has that of my p value is
uniform then I know it's uniform so it
means that the cumulative distribution
function has an intrinsic value about it
captures the entire distribution right
everything I need to know about my
distribution is captured by the
cumulative distribution function now I
have an empirical way of computing I
have a data-driven way of computing an
estimate for the cumulative distribution
function which is using the old
statistical trick which consists in
replacing expectations by averages all
right so as I said the the cumulative
distribution function for any
distribution for any random variable is
right so f of T
is the probability that X is less than
or equal to T which is equal to the
expectation of the indicator that X is
less than or equal to T all right that's
the definition of a probability and so
here I'm just gonna replace expectation
by the average right that's my usual
statistical trick
and so my estimator FN for the
distribution is going to be 1 over n sum
from I equal 1 to N of these indicators
ok and this is called the empirical the
CDF it's just the data version of the
CDF okay so I just replaced this
expectation here
by an average okay now when I sum
indicators
I'm actually counting the number of them
that satisfy something so if you look at
what this guy is this is the number of
excise that is less than T right and so
if I divide by n it's the proportion of
observations that have their own less
than T okay that's what the empirical
distribution so that's what's written
here the number of data points that are
less than T and so this is going to be
something that sort of tried to estimate
one or the other and the law of large
number actually tells me that for any
given T if n is large enough f n of T it
should be close to f of T right because
it's an average and this entire thing
this entire statistical trick which
consists in replacing expectations by
averages is justified by the law of
large number every time we used it that
was because the law of large number sort
of guarantee to us that the average was
close to the expectation
okay so law of large numbers tell me
that f n of T converges so that's the
strong law says that almost surely
actually f n of T goes to F of T okay
and that's just for any given T
everybody is there any question about
this right that averages converge to
expectation that's the law of large
number and almost surely we could say in
probability it's the same that would be
the weak law of large number now this is
fine for any given T the average
converges to the true right it just
happens that this random variable is
indexed by T and I could do it for T
equals 1 or 2 or 25 and just check it
again but I might want to check it for
all T's at once and that's actually a
different result that's called a uniform
result I want this to hold for all T at
the same time and it may be the case
that it works for each T individually
but not for all T's at the same time
what could happen is that for T equals 1
it converges at a certain rate and for T
equals 2 it converges at a bit of a
slower rate and for T equals 3 as at a
slower rate and slower rate and so as T
goes to infinity the rate is going to
vanish and nothing is gonna converge
that could happen I could make this
happen at a finite point there's many
ways where I couldn't make this happen
right let's see how that could work I
could say well actually no I still need
to have this at infinity for some reason
ok so turns out that this is still true
uniformly and this is actually a much
more complicated result than the law of
large number it's called livenko
Cantelli theorem and the glencoe could
tell the theorem tells me that for all
T's at once
FN converges to F ok so let me just tell
you I'll show you quickly why this is
just a little bit stronger than the one
that we we had so remember if soup is
confusing you think of max it's just a
max over an infinite set and so what we
know is that f n of t minus
goes to F of T as n goes to infinity and
let's say almost sure oh okay and that's
the large large numbers which is
equivalent to saying that F n of t minus
f of T as n goes to infinity converges
almost surely to zero right this is the
same thing now I want this to happen for
all T's at once okay and so what I'm
gonna do oh and this is actually
equivalent to this and so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna make it a little
stronger so here the arrow only goes one
way and this is where the soup for T and
R of F n of T okay and you can actually
show that this happens also almost
surely okay now maybe almost surely is a
bit more difficult to get a grasp on
does can somebody does somebody have
wood does anybody want to see it and
like why this statement for the soup is
strictly stronger than the one that
holds individually for all T's you want
to see that okay so let's do it
so forget about almost surely for one
second let's just do it for in
probability write the fact that f n of T
converges to F F F of T for all T in
probability means that this goes to zero
as n goes to infinity for any epsilon
right for any epsilon and T we don't we
have this that's the convergence in
probability now what I want is to put a
soup here right but the probability that
the soup is lower than Epsilon might be
actually always larger than never go to
to zero in some cases right it could be
the case that for each given T I can
make n large enough so that this is
small so that this probability becomes
small but then maybe it's an N of T
right so this here means that
for any say maybe I shouldn't put let me
put the Delta here so for any epsilon so
for any T there and for any epsilon
there exists n which could depend on on
both epsilon and T such that the
probability that F and G minus F of T
exceeding Delta is less than epsilon T
there existent and any delta no that's
for all Delta sorry so right so this is
true right so that's that's what the
this limit statement actually means but
it could be the case that that when I
take the soup over T maybe that n of T
is something that looks like tea or
maybe well integer part of T it could be
right
I don't say anything it's just an end
that depends on T so if this n is just T
maybe T over epsilon right because I
want epsilon something like this well
that means that if I want this to hold
for all T's at once I'm gonna have to go
for the T the N that works for all T's
at once but there's no such n that works
for all T's at once this is the only end
that works is infinity and so I cannot
make this happen for all of them
what banker can tell D tells you it's
actually this is not something that
holds like this that the N that depends
on T there's actually one largest n that
works for all the cheese at once and
that's it ok so just so you know why
this is actually a stronger statement
and and that's basically how how it
works
any other question yeah
no well the random verbal does have
finite mean and finite variance because
the random variable is an indicator so
it has everything you want this is one
of the nicest random variables this is a
burly random variable right so here when
I say a law of large number that this
holds where did I write this I think I
raised it yeah the one over there this
is actually a lot of large numbers for
Bernalillo random variables they have
everything you want they are bounded yes
so you mean this one for all epsilon and
all T so you fix them now that the
probability that I Excel sorry that was
Delta R a changed this epsilon to Delta
at some point oh so then the second line
says that for all so this is so the way
you so this I'm just rewriting in terms
of epsilon Delta what this end goes goes
to infinity means so that means that for
any well for any T and Delta right so
that's the same as this guy here then
here I'm just going back to rewriting
this it says that for any epsilon there
exist an N large enough such that well n
larger than this thing basically such
that this thing is less than Epsilon
okay so Glencoe Catelli tells us that
not only is this thing is good idea
point wise but it's also a good idea
uniformly and all it's saying is if you
actually were happy with just this
result you should be even happier with
that result and this both of those
results only tell you one thing they're
just telling you that the empirical CDF
is a good estimator of the CDF okay now
since those F those indicators are
Bernoulli distributions I can actually
do even more so let me get this guy here
okay so those guys a fan of tea
this guy is a Burnley distribution what
is the parameter of this Bernoulli
distribution what is the probability it
takes value 1 f of T right it's just the
probability that this thing happens
which is f of T so in particular the
variance of this guy is the variance of
this Bernoulli so it's F of T 1 minus F
of T and I can use that in my central
limit theorem and my name and central me
theorem is just gonna tell me that if I
look at the average of random variables
I remove their mean right so you look at
square root of n F n of T which I could
really write as xn bar right that's
really just an xn bar minus the
expectation which is f of T that comes
from this guy now if I divide by square
root of the variance that's my square
root P 1 minus P then this guy by the
central limit theorem goes to sum n 0 1
okay which is the same thing as you see
there except that the variance was put
on the other side okay do I have the
same thing uniformly in T right can I
write something that holds uniformly in
T well if you think about it for one
second it's unlikely it's gonna go to
well in the sense that it's unlikely
that the supremum of those random
variables over T is going to also be a
Gaussian right and the reason is
that well actually the reason is that
this thing is actually a stochastic
process index by t a stochastic process
is just a sequence and random variables
that's in the XY say time one the one
that the most famous is the brown and
brown and motion and it's basically a
bunch of Gaussian increments right so
when you go from T to just T a little
after that you have to just add some gas
into the thing and and here it's
basically the same thing that's
happening and you would sort of expect
since each of this guy is Gaussian you
would expect to see something that looks
like a Brownian motion at the end but
it's not exactly a round motion it's
something that's called a Brownian
bridge so if you've seen the brown
motion is something if I make it start
at zero for example so this is the value
of my Brownian motion let's write it so
this is one path one realization of
Brown let's call it W of T as T
increases so it's let's say it starts at
zero and it looks like something like
this right so that's what Brown motion
looks like it's just something that's
pretty nasty and but it it's I mean it
looks pretty nasty it's not continuous
etc but it's actually very very benign
in some average way okay and so Brown
motion is just something what you should
view this as if I sum some random
variable there are Gaussian and then I
look at at this farther it from farther
and farther it's gonna look like this
and so here I cannot have a Brown motion
in the end because what is the value at
what is the variance of F n of T minus f
of T at T is equal to 1 sorry at T is
equal to infinity
it's zero right the variance goes from 0
at T is negative infinity because that
negative infinity f of T is going to
zero and at F at T as T goes to plus
infinity f of T is going to 1 which
means that the variance of this guy as T
goes from negative infinity to plus
infinity is Penda to be zero on each
side and so my Brannon motion cannot
correct when I describe aberrant motion
I'm just like adding more and more
entropy to the thing and it's going all
over the place but here
what I want is that as I go back it
should go back to essentially zero it
should be pinned down to a specific
value at the end and that's actually
called a Brownian bridge it's a brand
motion that's conditioned to come back
to where it started essentially now you
don't need to understand brown bridges
to understand what I'm gonna be telling
you what the only thing I want to
communicate to you is that this guy here
when I say a Brannon bridge I can go to
any parabola stand they can tell you all
the probability properties of this
stochastic process it can tell me the
probability it takes any value at any
point in particular it can tell me the
supreme amines Eero and one of this guy
it can tell me what the cumulative
distribution function of this thing is
can tell me what the density of this
thing is can tell me everything so it
means that if I want to compute
probabilities on this object here which
is the maximum value that this guy can
take over a certain period of time which
is basically this random variable rights
if I look at the value here it's a
random variable that fluctuates it can
tell me where it is with high
probability can tell me the quintiles of
this thing and it tell can tell me which
is useful because I can build a table
and use it to compute my quintiles and
perform tasks from it okay so that's
what actually is quite nice it says that
if I look at this square root of n FN
hat now soup over T I get something that
looks like this soup of this gaussians
but it's the early soup of gas and it's
super of a brown motion now there's
something you should be very careful
here I cheated a little bit I mean I
didn't cheat I can do whatever I want
but my notation might be a little
confusing everybody sees that this T
here is not the same as this T here can
somebody see that right just because
first of all this guy's between 0 & 1
and this guy's between these all in all
of our what is this T here as a function
of this T here
this guy is F of this guy okay so really
if I want it to be completely
transparent and not you know save the
cheese of my keyboard I would write this
as soup over t FN t minus F of T goes to
and distribution as n goes to infinity
the supremum over t again in R so this
guy is for T in the entire real line
this guy's 14 the entire real line but
now I should write B of what F of T
exactly
so really the T here is F of the
original one and so that's a Brownian
motion that's a Brownian bridge where
when T goes to infinity the Brownian
bridge goes from 0 to 1 and it looks
like this a Brownian bridge at 0 is 0 at
1 is 0 it does this but it doesn't stray
too far because I conditioned it to come
back to this point that's what a brown
bridges okay so in particular I can find
a distribution for this guy and I can
use this to build a test which is called
the kolmogorov-smirnov test okay so the
year is the following it's as well if I
were if I want to chat some distribution
if not some distribution that has a
particular CDF F dot and I plug it in
under the null then this guy should have
pretty much the same distribution as
this supremum of Brownian bridge and so
if I see this to be much larger than it
should be when it's the supreme of a
Brownian bridge I'm actually going to
reject my hypothesis ok so here's the
test I want to test whether h0
F is equal to F zero and you will see
that most of the the goodness-of-fit
tests are formulated mathematically in
terms of the cumulative distribution
function I could formulate them in terms
of probability density function or just
write x follows and zero one but that's
the way we write it we formulate them in
terms of cumulative distribution
function because that's what we have a
handle on through the empirical
community of distribution function okay
and then it's vs. h1 F is not equal to f
0 okay so now I have my empirical CDF
and I hope that for all T's F n of T
should be close to f0 of T ok like this
I put it two on the exponent because
otherwise that would be I have F the
empirical distribution function based on
zero observations all right so now I
form the following test statistic okay
so my test statistic is TN which is the
supremum over T in the real line of
square root of n FN of T minus F of T
sorry F 0 of T so I can compute
everything I know this from the data and
this is the one that comes from my null
hypothesis I can compute this thing and
I know that if this is true this should
actually be the supremum of a Brownian
bridge pretty much okay and so the
kolmogorov-smirnov test
is simply reject if this guy TN in
absolute value right there's no actually
not in absolute value this is just
already absolute valued then this guy
should be what well it should be larger
then the Q alpha over 2 distribution
that I have but now rather than putting
and 0 1 or TN this is here whatever
notation I have first premium of
Brownian bridge okay just like I did for
any pivotal distribution right that was
the same recipe every single time I form
the test statistic such that the
asymptotic distribution did not depend
on anything I know and then I would just
reject when this pivotal distribution
was larger than something yes do you
know what it brown in bridges or okay so
this thing here is think of it as being
a Gaussian right so for all T you have a
Gaussian distribution okay now a
Brownian motion so if I so if I had a
Brownian motion I need to tell you what
the so it's basically a brown motion is
something that looks like this it's some
random variable that's indexed by T I
won't say the expectation of XT to be
equal to 0 for all T ok and what I want
is that the increments have a certain
distribution okay so what I want is that
the expectation of X T minus X s follows
some distribution which is n 0 t minus s
ok so the increments are bigger as I go
farther in terms of variability and I
also want some covariance structure
between the two right so what I want is
that the covariance between X s and X
team
is actually equal to the minimum of S&T
yeah maybe there should be that okay so
this is you know you open a probability
book that's what it's gonna look like so
in particularly you can see if I put 0
here as T goes to int and X 0 is equal
to 0 it has 0 variance and it's so in
particular it means that XT if I look
only at the cheap one it has some normal
distribution with variance T so this is
something that just blows up so this guy
here it looks like it's gonna be a brown
motion because when I look at the
left-hand side it has a normal
distribution now there's a bunch of
other things you need to check is the
fact that you have this covariance for
example which I did not tell you but it
should look somewhat somewhat like that
in particular when I look at the normal
with mean 0 and and variance here then
it's clear that this guy does not have a
variance that's gonna go to infinity
just like the variance of this guy we
know that the variance is forced to be
back to 0 okay and so in particular we
have something that has mean 0 always
whose variance has to be 0 at 0 and the
variance story at t equals negative
infinity and variance 1 at t equals plus
infinity so variance 0 at t equals plus
infinity and so i have to basically
force it to be equal to 0 at each end so
the brown motion here tends to just go
to infinity somewhere whereas this guy
forced it to come back now everything i
described to you is on the scale 0
negative infinity to plus infinity but
since everything depends on f of t i can
actually just put that back into a scale
which is 0 and 1 by a chain is simple
change of variable it's like it's called
change of time for the brown motion ok
yeah
yeah I mean they're definitely it's
gonna be I mean it by symmetry you can
probably infer all the things right so
yes so I don't know exactly explicit
formula for the span it's simple that's
what I can tell you but I don't know
what the explicit I'd at the top of my
head with the explicit formula is ya
know well the brown one Britt this is
the supreme are you right so this is
yeah so right so this will be this form
for the variance for sure because this
is only marginal distribution that don't
take right the process is not just what
is the distribution at each instant t
it's also how do those distributions
interact with each other right in terms
of coherent but for the marginal
distributions at each instant T right
the variance is f of T 1 minus f of T
that's not gonna we're not gonna escape
that but then the covariance structure
between those guys is a little more
complicated but yes you're right for
marginal that's enough yeah yeah it
could be infinity
okay because what I did I raise it yeah
because here I didn't say the supremum
of the absolute value of a bearing
bridge i just said the supremum of a
brown bridge but you're right let's just
do this like that and then and then it's
it's probably cleaner right so yeah
actually well I should be Q alpha so
this is basically you're right so this
is think of it as being one-sided and
there's actually no symmetry for the
supremum right so I mean the supreme is
not symmetric around zero and so so
you're right I should not use alpha over
two thank you any other question
there should be alpha yeah I mean those
slides were written with I minus alpha
and I have not replaced all instances of
one minus alpha by alpha I mean except
this guy still day well it depends on
how you want to call it but this is
still the probability that Z the verrat
Z exists this guy should be alpha okay
and this can be found in tables and we
can compute the p-value just like we did
before but we have to simulate it
because it's not going to depend on the
cumulative distribution function of a
Gaussian like it did for the usual
gastrin test it's something that's more
complicated and typically you don't even
try you get the statistical software to
do it for you okay so just let me let me
skip a few lines this is what the table
looks like for the kolmogorov-smirnov
test okay so it just tells you what is
your some number of observations and
then you want alpha to be equal to 5%
say let's say you have nine observations
so if square root of an absolute value
of f n of t minus f of t exceeds this
thing you reject okay
so what's pretty clear from this test is
that it looks very nice and I tell you
this is how you build it but if you're
thinking about it for one second
it's actually really an annoying thing
to build because you have to take the
supremum over t right this depends on
computing your supremum which you know
practice might be super cumbersome I
don't want you have to compute this for
all values T and then take the maximum
of those guys it turns out that it's
actually quite nice that we don't have
to actually do this what does the
empirical distribution function look
like well this thing remember f n of T
by definition was so let me go to the
slide that's relevant so FN of T looks
like this so what it means is that when
T is between two observations then this
guy is actually keeping the same value
so if I put my observations on the real
line here so let's say I have one
observation here one observation here
one observation here one of the relation
here and one observation here for
simplicity then this guy is basically up
to this normalization counting how many
observations I have that are less than T
right so since I normalized by n I know
that the smallest number here is going
to be 0 and the largest number here is
going to be 1 ok so let's say this looks
like this this is the value 1 ok add the
value since I take it less than or equal
to when I'm at X I am actually counting
it so the jump happens at X I so that's
the first observation and then I jump by
how much do I jump yeah 1 over N right
okay and then this value belongs to to
the right and then I do it again
I'm gonna I know I'm not gonna work out
for me but we'll see that's actually I
did pretty well okay this is what my
cumulative distribution looks like now
if you look at this light there's this
weird notation where I start putting now
my indices in parenthesis X parenthesis
one experiences two etc those are called
the ordered statistic it's just because
it might be you know when my dealer is
given to me I just call the first
observation the one that's on top of the
table but isn't it it doesn't have to be
the smallest value so it might be that
this is x1 and that this is x2 then this
is X 3 X 4 and X 5 right this might be
my observations so what I do is that I
call them in such a way that this is
actually I recall this guy X 1 which is
just really X 3 this is X 2 X 3 X 4 and
X 5 these are my reordered observations
in such a way that the smallest one is
indexed by one and the largest one is
indexed by n ok so now this is actually
quite nice because what I'm trying to do
is to find the largest deviation from
this guy to the true cumulative
distribution function the true
cumulative distribution function let's
say it's Gaussian looks like this all
right something continues for a
symmetric distribution it crosses this
axis at 1/2 and that's what it looks
like and you believe the the kamakura of
smirnoff steps is just telling me how
far do I get those two curves get in the
worst possible case right so in
particular here where are they the
farthest clearly at this point and so up
to rescaling this is the value I'm gonna
be interested in that's how they get as
far as possible from each other here
something just happened right the
farthest distance that I got was exactly
at one of those dots it turns out this
is enough to look at those dots
and the reason is well because after
this dot and until the next jump this
guy does not change but this guy
increases and so the the only point
where they can be the farthest apart is
either to the left at one to the left of
a jumper to the right of a job that's
the only place where they can be far
from each other and that means that only
one observation everybody sees that the
farthest points the points at which
those two curves are the farthest from
each other has to be at one of the
observations and so rather than looking
at a soup over all possible tees really
all I need to do is to look at a maximum
only at my observations right I just
need to check at each of those points
whether they're far now here notice that
you did not this is not written F n of X
I the reason is because I actually know
what F n of X is f n of the eighth order
observation is just the number of jumps
I've had until this observation so here
I know that the value of F n is 1 over n
here it's 2 over n 3 over N 4 over N 5
over n so I know that the values of F n
at my observations and those are
actually the only values that f n can
take are an integer divided by n and
that's why you see I minus 1 over N or I
over N this is the difference just
before the jump and this is the
difference at the jump ok so here the
key message is that this is no longer
supreme over all T's but it's just a
maximum from 1 to n so I really have
only two n values to compute this value
and this value for each observation
that's 2n total I look at the maximum
and that's actually the value and it's
actually equal to TN those are things
it's done an approximation those things
are equal that's just the only places
where those guys can be maximum okay
yes
Oh strictly less powerful
so can you I'm not sure what question
you're asking yes yeah yeah so remember
here in this test we want to conclude to
a zero in the other test we typically
want to conclude two h1 so here we
actually don't want power in the way and
and you have to also assume that doing a
test on the mean it's probably not the
only thing you're going to end up doing
on your data after after you actually
establish that it's normally distributed
then you have a data set you've sort of
established it's normally distributed
and then you can just run the arsenal of
statistical studies and we're gonna see
regression and all sorts of prediction
predictive things which are not just
just test if the mean is equal to
something maybe you want to build a
confidence interval for the mean then
this is not the comparison rule is not a
test right so you're gonna have to first
test if it's normal and then see if you
can actually use the quantiles of a
Gaussian distribution or a T
distribution to build this confidence
interval so in a way you should do this
is like you know the flat fee to enter
the gaussian world and then you can do
whatever you want to do in the gaussian
world we'll see actually that your
question goes back to something that's a
little more that's a little important
here I said F 0 is fully specified right
it's like an N 1 5 but I didn't say is
it Gauss is it normally distributed
which is the question that everybody
asks right you're not asking is it this
particular normal distribution with this
particular mean in this particular
variance so how would you do it in
practice well you would say I'm just
gonna replace the mean by the empirical
mean and the variance by the empirical
variance but by doing that you're making
a huge mistake
because you're sort of depriving your
test of the possibility to reject the
Gaussian hypothesis just based on the
fact that the mean is wrong or the
variance is wrong
you've already stuck to your data pretty
well okay and so you're sort of like
already you know tilting the game in
favor of h0 big time
so there's actually a weight
you arrange for this okay so this is
about pivotal statistic we've used this
word many time and okay so that's how
I'm not gonna go into this test it's
really this is a recipe on how you would
actually build the table that I showed
you right this table this is basically
the recipe on how to build it there's
another recipe to build it which is just
open a book at this page alright that's
a little faster or use the software I
just wanted to show you so let's just
keep in mind anybody has a good memory
let's just keep in mind this number this
is the the threshold for the comma
grossman of statistic if I have 10
observations and I want to do it at 5%
okay
it's about 41% so that's the number that
it should be larger from so it turns out
that if you want to test if it's normal
and not just a specific normal this
number is going to be different do you
think the number I'm gonna read in a
table that's appropriate for this is
gonna be larger or smaller
who says larger so the question is this
is the number I should see if my test
was is X say n 0 5 right that's a
specific distribution with a specific F
0 right so that's the number that's I
would build the comma graph smear enough
statistic from this I would perform a
test and check if my como gross man of
statistic TN is larger than this number
or not okay if its larger I'm gonna
reject no I say actually I don't want to
test if a 0 is + 0 5 but it's just a new
Sigma squared for some mu and Sigma
squared
and in particular I'm just gonna plug in
your hat and Sigma hat into my F 0 run
the same statistic but compare it to a
different number should this so the
larger the number the more or less
likely I am to reject the less likely I
am to reject right so if I just use that
number
I would let's say this is the large
number I would be more tempted to say
it's Gaussian
if you look at the table you would get
if you make the appropriate correction
at the same number of observations 10
and the same level you get to 25% as
opposed to 41% that means that you're
actually much more likely if you use the
appropriate tests to reject the fact
that it's normal which is bad news
because that means you don't have access
to the gaussian Arsenal and nobody wants
to do this so actually this is a mistake
that people do a lot they use the comb
over of smear test to test for normality
without adjusting for the fact that
they've plugged in the estimated mean
and the estimated variance this leads to
rejecting less often right I mean this
is almost half of the number that we had
and then there can be happy and more
calm and said well I did the test and it
was normal so this is actually a mistake
that I believe that genuinely at least a
quarter of the people do make in purpose
they say well I wanted it to be Gaussian
so I'm just gonna make my life easier
alright so this is the so-called
Kolmogorov leader force test we'll talk
about it well not today for sure there's
other statistics that you can test that
you can use and the idea is to say well
we want to know if the empirical
distribution function the empirical CDF
is close to the true CDF the way we did
it is by forming the difference in
looking at the worst possible distance
they can be that's called a soup norm or
L infinity norm in in functional
analysis so here this is what it looked
like right the distance between F N and
F that we measured was just the supremum
distance over all T's that's one way to
measure distance between two functions
but there's an infinite way many ways to
measure distance between functions one
is something we're much more familiar
with which is d squared l 2-norm
this is nice because this has like inner
inner product it has some nice
properties and you could actually just
rather than taking the soup you could
just integrate the squared distance and
this is what leads to crime Ervin misses
tasks and then there's another one that
says well maybe I don't want to
integrate without weights maybe I want
to put weights that accounts for the
variance and this guy is called Anderson
darling for each of this test you can
check that the syntactic distribution
is going to be pivotal which means that
there will be a table at the back of
some book that tells you what the
statistic the the quintiles of square
root of n times this guy are
asymptotically basically yeah yeah yeah
so that's just to show you that
asymptotically is people oh and I can
point you to one specific specific thing
but it turns out that this thing is
actually pivotal for each N and that's
why you have this recipe to construct
the entire thing because it's actually
not true for all possible ends also
there's the end that shows up here so no
actually this is just something you
should have in mind okay so basically
let me let me strike what I just said
this thing you can actually this
distribution will not depend on F zero
for any particular n it's just not gonna
be a Brownian bridge but a finite sample
approximation of a Brown bridge and you
can simulate that just drawing samples
from it building a histogram and
constructing the quintiles for this guy
oh there is one that's the table right
maybe yeah let's see if we see it at the
bottom of the other table yeah see over
40 and we're thirty so this is not the
kolmogorov-smirnov but that's the coma
guerrilla force those numbers that you
see here they're in the numbers for the
asymptotic thing which is some sort of
Barron bridge yeah yeah
so then you won't have this nice picture
right
this can happen at any point because
you're gonna have this continuity's in F
and those things can happen everywhere
and then oh you mean the brown bridge no
no but you still need it you still need
it for so there's there's some finite
sample versions of it that you can use
that are slightly more conservative so
which is in great wave good news because
you're gonna conclude more to h0 and
there's some you know forget the name
it's Keefer Wolfe of it's the Keefer
baretsky Wolfe of it's an equality which
is basically like happenings inequality
so it's basically up to bad constants
telling you the same result as the
Brownian bridge result and those are
true all the time but for the exactly
the asymptotic distribution you need
continually yes yes
well if you know what they are you can
use comb-over of smirnoff but if you
don't know what they are you're gonna
plug in as soon as you're gonna estimate
the mean and the variance from the data
you're gonna you should use the one
where see you next time which is called
comb-over of Lili force don't have to
think about it too much we'll talk about
it don't Thursday yeah
any other question so we were out of
time so I think we should stop here and
we'll see ya well we'll resume on
Thursday